IT'S UP TO CONGRESS.
NEIL?
>> Neil: OKAY.
I THINK I UNDERSTAND THAT.
PETER DOOCY AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
LET'S GO TO JIM TRUSTY, THE
FORMER PROSECUTOR.
JIM, HELP ME WITH THIS.
LET'S SAY THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OVERTURNS THIS AND THE MASKS
HAVE TO BE BACK ON.
THEN WE HAVE TO PUT THEM BACK ON
PLANES, THAT IS INSTANTLY THE
CASE?
>> IT'S POSSIBLE.
THE ONLY RAY OF SUNSHINE I'M
GETTING FROM THIS SO FAR, THEY
HAVE NOT MOVED TO STAY THE
OPINION.
A LOT OF TIMES WHEN YOU NOTE AN
APPEAL, YOU GO TO THE COURT OR
THE NEXT COURT, THE 11th CIRCUIT
AND SAY WE HAVE TO STOP THIS
FROM TAKING EFFECT.
THEY HAVEN'T DONE IT YET.
THAT'S A MILDLY GOOD SIGN.
THERE'S SOME POSSIBILITY OF WHAT
YOU REFER TO AS A PROTECTIVE
NOTICE OF APPEAL SAYING HEY,
WE'VE NOTED THE APOLE AND WILL
FIGURE IT OUT BEFORE A BRIEFING.
I'M HOPING THAT COOLER HEADS
JUMP IN AND GET US TO A POINT
THAT THEY WITHDRAW THAT APPEAL
SOME DAY.
MIGHT BE A FOOL'S ERRAND
THINKING THAT WAY BUT HOPEFUL
THAT THAT IS THE POSSIBILITY.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
OTHERWISE WE COULD BE ON THIS
CRAZY SEESAW.
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION BEFORE
THE BREAK, I WOULDN'T BRING A
MASK.
I'D BRING A PARACHUTE.
THE PEOPLE ON THE PLANE WILL GO
NOTICE IF THEY GET THE REVERSE
ANNOUNCEMENT DURING A FLIGHT.
>> Neil: I WONDERED ABOUT THAT.
I'M NOT A LAWYER, BUT I WATCHED
ENOUGH LEGAL SHOWS THAT I
QUALIFY.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT COMMON
SENSE HERE.
WHY CAN'T -- SINCE THIS
ORIGINATED FROM A CDC
RECOMMENDATION, WHY CAN'T THE
CDC GO BACK AND JUST SAY THAT'S
AN OPTION?
WE THINK IT'S WISE FOR YOU TO
KEEP A MASK ON, BUT THAT'S UP TO
YOU.
END OF STORY?
>> YEAH, THEY COULD.
SO YOUR LAW AND ORDER EPISODES
ARE PAYING OFF.
THE ISSUE IN TERMS OF THIS
RULING IS NOT REALLY DIRECTLY
ABOUT THE WISDOM OF WEARING
MASKS.
IT'S ABOUT THE AUTHORITY OF THE
CDC.
OF A FEDERAL AGENCY TO CONTROL
INDIVIDUAL CONDUCT.
IT'S A FEDERALISM NOTION.
THAT'S SOMETHING THE WHITE HOUSE
IS LOSING TRACK OF.
A MUDDLED MESSAGE.
HARD TO KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
THEY ALSO HAVE SOMETHING
FUNDAMENTALLY BACKWARDS HERE.
WHEN YOU HAVE AN ADVERSE RULING
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE,
IT'S THE LAWYER'S THAT WILL MAKE
THE ULTIMATE DECISIONS ABOUT
APPEALS.
SPECIFICALLY THE SOLICITOR
GENERAL SAYS THEY, DID THEY GET
THIS WRONG?
IS THERE AN INJUSTICE HERE OR DO
WE JUST BASICALLY TAKE IT AND
LET THE CASE BE THE LAW OF THE
LAND?
YOU DON'T JUST TURN BACK TO THE
CLIENT, IN THIS CASE CDC AND SAY
GOSH, GUYS, YOU'RE SO BRILLIANT,
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO?
THEY DON'T DECIDE THE APPEAL?
DOJ DOES.
THIS IS REALLY BACKWARDS THAT
WE'RE HEARING THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS THAT CDC THINKS IT'S
IMPORTANT AND THEY'RE KNOWING
AND ALL-POWERFUL SO WE'LL APPEAL
IT.
THAT'S NOT THE WAY THE PROCESS
SHOULD BE WORKING.
>> Neil: WELL-EXPLAINED.
YOU SHOULD STICK TO THIS LAW
THING.
YO